el vídeo de hoy ha sido posible gracias
a italkie más sobre esto En un momento
[Música]
más de una década de infrainversión en
la industria de extracción de gas y
petróleo junto a la invasión rusa de
Ucrania han creado la profunda crisis
energética que hoy está castigando
duramente a muchas economías a lo largo
y ancho de todo el mundo una crisis que
ahora amenaza especialmente a la vieja
Europa sin embargo en esta crisis hay
más protagonistas y no en esta ocasión
nos vamos a hablar ni de las energías
renovables ni tampoco de la nuclear No
ni siquiera del hidrógeno sino de algo
que quizás es mucho más importante a
corto y medio plazo para garantizar el
suministro energético entre los viejos
clientes de la Rusia de Putin por
supuesto nos estamos refiriendo al gas
natural licuado o lng por sus siglas en
inglés este es ya uno de los grandes
protagonistas de la actualidad
geoeconómica internacional el recurso
clave que condicionará la economía
mundial Durante los próximos años pero
antes de continuar dejadme que os
sabías que España es el segundo país en
la Unión Europea con peor dominio del
inglés y sí ya lo sé siempre podemos
tener la tentación de utilizar la excusa
de que bueno que al fin y al cabo con un
idioma tan fuerte y tan importante como
es el español no es tan imprescindible
dominar una segunda lengua pero a ver en
serio realmente te lo crees no tendrá
más sentido aprovechar la fortaleza de
ser nativos en español y sumarnos un
segundo idioma fuerte como el inglés de
hecho y ojo que esto es importante aquí
podemos jugar incluso con ventaja los
hablantes nativos de inglés no se
caracterizan por dominar las lenguas de
hecho solo un 20% de los estudiantes de
primaria y secundaria en los Estados
Unidos estudian un segundo idioma frente
al 92% de los europeos vamos que si lo
jugamos bien Podemos convertir nuestra
debilidad en toda una fortaleza Pues
bien justo Aquí es donde entra italkie
con Idol key podrás darle un empujón a
tu inglés con la ayuda de profesores
nativos certificados solo elegir el tipo
de clase que más se ajuste a tus
necesidades conversación pronunciación
negocios por ejemplo para entrevistas de
trabajo preparación de exámenes y no hay
suscripciones y nada parecido pagas por
cada clase sin ningún compromiso y como
sé que os gustan los datos aquí va otro
se estima que 19 horas en itowski
equivalen a un semestre universitario En
definitiva ponte las pilas y coge el
toro por los cuernos y ojo no tiene por
qué ser inglés tienes más de 150 idiomas
donde elegir a lo mejor crees que te
viene mejor diferenciarte y lanzarte a
por el yo que sé el coreano o a por el
Alemán o el chino Por ejemplo yo
personalmente llevo usándolo desde hace
cuatro años quise que nos Vais a repetir
no esperes más regístrate ya de forma
gratuita en itulky con el link que te
dejamos abajo en la descripción y ahora
sí vayamos con el vídeo de hoy
[Música]
[Aplausos]
el gas natural licuado es básicamente
gas en estado líquido esto se consigue
gracias a un proceso llamado
licuefacción en el que el gas extraído
se enfría hasta unos
160 grados bajo cero
[Música]
de este modo a 160 grados bajo cero
helga se convierte en líquido ocupando
mucho menos volumen aproximadamente
Hablamos de una relación de 1 a 600 es
decir que un determinado volumen de gas
natural licuado ocuparía 600 veces más
en estado gaseoso Esto hace que se pueda
transportar en grandes barcos metaneros
y claro el transporte por vía marítima
permite que aquellos países que no
tengan conexiones por gasoducto con los
productores puedan importar grandes
cantidades de gas incluso desde lugares
muy distantes
hasta ahora todo parecen ventajas verdad
y lo cierto Es que las tienen en 1964
entró en servicio el primer barco
dedicado en exclusiva a la exportación
de lng
[Música]
fue la puesta en marcha de una
tecnología que en los últimos 20 años ha
crecido vertiginosamente hasta hoy se
han completado más de 80.000 transportes
de gnl en todo el mundo y ya son más de
600 Los buques activos que transportan
el gas desde los países productores como
Qatar hasta las calderas de los
consumidores desde Japón hasta España
toda una Revolución en 2021 los tres
mayores consumidores de gnl Fueron por
este orden china Japón y Corea del Sur
fijaos las ventajas están claras a un
solo tenemos que mirar a Japón y Corea
del Sur 2 Islas energéticas que gracias
a esta tecnología han podido acceder a
un suministro abundante y relativamente
barato de gas natural ahora bien todo
apunta a que la importancia del gas
natural adecuado se va a disparar
Durante los próximos años
aproximadamente el 40% de todo el gas
que se consumía en Europa procedía
directamente por tuberías de Rusia y
este gas llegaba a raudales y a precios
tan bajos que los países europeos Se
volvieron enormemente dependientes hasta
ahora la Guerra de Ucrania lo ha
cambiado absolutamente todo y no se
trata solo de la guerra la Rusia de
Putin ha demostrado no ser un socio
confiable y eso en términos energéticos
lo cambia todo ahora pase lo que pase en
ningún país europeo estará dispuesto a
volver a depender tanto de Rusia El
problema es que hasta ahora no se ha
construido la infraestructura necesaria
para poder sustituir a este país y es
que claro teniendo un gas tan barato
para que invertir en costosas
infraestructuras de gas Como por ejemplo
las plantas regasificadoras
[Música]
ojo hubo excepciones ahí que envió el
peligro muy claro desde el principio
fijaos lituania se convierte en el
primer estado miembro de la Unión
Europea en abandonar el gas ruso caen la
luz verde la decisión de adquirir la
fsru independent lituano de la terminal
de lng ha aprobado la decisión de
adquirir la frú independencia una vez
que termine el acuerdo de arrendamiento
en 2024 este pequeño estado Báltico de
menos de 3 millones de habitantes Ha
logrado en un tiempo
récord deshacerse completamente del gas
ruso
la conseguido gracias a que en 2014 puso
en servicio la planta regasificadora
flotante indipendens lo hizo
precisamente para llegado el caso poder
prescindir de Rusia además esta
infraestructura le está permitiendo al
país Báltico exportar el gnl ya
regocificado a letonia Estonia y
Finlandia Por cierto sabéis De dónde
procede mayoritariamente el gas que
opera esta planta exacto de Estados
Unidos y ojo en un momento veremos que
este apunte es clave en cualquier caso
la pregunta que puede que os estáis
haciendo es cómo demonios es posible que
un pequeño país como lituania apostase
en 2014 por tener alternativas a Rusia y
así garantizar su seguridad energética
mientras otros como Alemania no hicieron
absolutamente nada quizás estos
titulares Tengan algo que ver se
sospecha que espías rusos infiltraron en
el gobierno alemán según un informe el
servicio de inteligencia nacional
estaría investigando a dos funcionarios
que trabajan en el campo del suministro
de energía pero como os decimos eso
ahora ha cambiado
[Música]
la Guerra de Ucrania las sanciones el
chantaje energético del kremlin todo
esto está obligando a que Europa busque
alternativas a Rusia y como los vecinos
que pueden suministrar gas por tuberías
como Argelia azerbaiyán o incluso Israel
no alcanzan para sustituir a Rusia ahora
en el viejo continente resuenan tres
siglas por todas las esquinas
lng pero claro para que Europa pueda
comenzar a utilizar lng en grandes
cantidades hacen falta cuatro cosas
primero una producción de gas suficiente
segundo plantas licofactoras en origen
tercero metaneros disponibles y cuarto
plantas reclasificadoras suficientes en
el destino esto es básicamente la cadena
del gas natural licuado y como en el
centro de Europa andan muy escasos en
los próximos meses y años es casi seguro
que veremos grandes inversiones la
guerra nucleania pone de nuevo sobre la
mesa a los planes para las terminales de
lng alemanas la carrera por nueva
infraestructura de importación de lng se
acelera de momento y a pesar de todas
las limitaciones las importaciones de
gnl están batiendo récords
[Música]
Por cierto sabéis Cuál es el país
europeo con más infraestructuras de gnl
321 Exacto España os hemos hablado ya de
ello aquí en visualpolitik
fijaos en este mapa en él podemos ver la
red Europea y como podéis comprobar
España es con mucha diferencia el país
con más regasificadoras operativas
España tiene Ni más ni menos que el 27%
de toda la capacidad de regasificación
de Europa y más de un tercio de la
capacidad de almacenaje en 2021 España
usó algo menos de un tercio de toda esta
capacidad es decir que el excedente para
poder suministrar Europa sería bastante
grande sin embargo hay un problema
España es una isla energética solo hay
un gaseoducto que cruza Francia y su
capacidad es muy limitada Y para colmo
ahora los franceses no quieren saber
nada de esta posibilidad
[Música]
el Alemán holaf sold promete un
gasoducto que una España y Portugal con
Europa España dice que el gasoducto a
Francia es posible en 8 o 9 meses
Francia frustra la mayor esperanza de
Alemania de reactivar su economía
funcionarios españoles sugieren que
París tenía una competencia a sus
exportaciones de hidrógeno París asegura
que el plan de Berlín es impráctico y
estúpido al ministerio francés le irrita
que llevaría muchos años completar solo
la planificación y otra documentación ya
sabéis cosas de Europa ahora bien un
momento porque en cualquier caso con
tener la infraestructura no basta hacen
falta también proveedores y actualmente
eso no resulta nada fácil la industria
está trabajando prácticamente a su
máxima capacidad y las nuevas
inversiones tardarán Algunos años en
poder suministrar más gas sin embargo se
confía que un país puede venir al
rescate de Europa por supuesto cobrando
la correspondiente factura adivináis de
quién estamos hablando atentos
Estados Unidos última esperanza de
Europa
en un pasado vídeo os contamos Cómo
Qatar se ha convertido en uno de los
grandes reyes de la exportación de gas
natural licuado con Australia y Estados
Unidos es una de las tres grandes
potencias de gnl de todo el mundo sin
embargo el país del Golfo Pérsico tiene
un problema la inmensa mayoría del
gnlcaribe está ya sujeto a contratos de
largo plazo Especialmente con países
asiáticos esto significa que apenas
tienen margen para responder al
repentino incremento de la demanda en
Europa Así que las importaciones de gnl
catariz mediante compras puntuales barco
por barco lo que se conoce como mercado
spot pueden ayudar pero marginalmente a
corto plazo no será una alternativa
viable al menos hasta finales de 2025
cuando se espera que entren en
funcionamiento las primeras fases de la
enorme ampliación de producción y está
desarrollando el país árabe y con
Australia pasa algo parecido además la
distancia favorece que las ventas se
dirijan mayoritariamente a otros países
de Asia digamos que la menor
circunstancia hace que un barco pueda
hacer más viajes de ida y vuelta lo que
incrementa las ventas de gas
[Música]
sin embargo la situación de los Estados
Unidos es muy diferente en este caso su
mercado spot tiene más margen entre
otras cosas porque la potencia
norteamericana tiene enormes gigantescas
descomunales cantidades de gas que hasta
hace unos pocos años no exportaba sin
embargo ahora se han puesto las pilas
para poder hacerlo el negocio promete
ser multimillonario fijaos otra vez en
el gráfico que veíamos hace tan solo un
momento habéis visto cómo están
creciendo las exportaciones de los
Estados Unidos pues queridos amigos
amigas justo Aquí está depositada la
gran esperanza de Europa
[Música]
Estados Unidos ha convertido en el país
clave para que Europa pueda sustituir
buena parte del gas ruso en un plazo
razonable de tiempo por ejemplo el
objetivo que hoy tiene la Unión Europea
es que como muy tarde para el 2027 los
países miembros puedan prescindir
completamente del gas ruso
Estados Unidos se ha convertido en el
mayor exportador de lng al canalizar el
suministro a los consumidores europeos a
Merced de Rusia ya lo veis la industria
norteamericana se está abriendo paso a
toda pastilla y Europa se ha convertido
en su cliente preferido si en 2021
Estados Unidos exportó de media el 29%
de todo su gnl Europa en los primeros
tres meses de 2022 más del 60% del gas
natural licuado americano fue a parar al
viejo continente ahora bien la pregunta
es realmente tiene tanto gas Estados
Unidos pues lo cierto es que sí fijaos
en este gráfico
[Música]
lo que estáis viendo es la producción de
gas natural de Estados Unidos como veis
la producción que se sitúa en máximos
históricos se ha disparado en los
últimos 15 años gracias a una tecnología
que lo cambió todo el fracking de hecho
el gas de esquisto que es como se conoce
al producido por fracking supuso en
torno al
79% de todo el gas producido en Estados
Unidos en 2021 un enorme crecimiento en
la producción de gas que ha hecho que la
producción supere ampliamente al consumo
lo que ahora sí les permite poder
exportarlo en grandes cantidades os lo
hemos contado aquí ya en pasados vídeos
en visualpolitik la tecnología del
fracking ha supuesto un antes y un
después
[Música]
ahora las reservas potenciales de
petróleo y de gas se ha multiplicado
Esta es una realidad que Estados Unidos
está aprovechando intensamente para
finales de esta década se espera que
Estados Unidos le exporte a Europa al
menos un tercio de todo el gas que el
viejo continente le compraba a Rusia
pero la oportunidad no es exclusivamente
suya entre otras cosas porque como veis
no es suficiente incluso teniendo en
cuenta las nuevas capacidades de Qatar y
de otros muchos países sustituir
completamente las compras a Rusia parece
una Misión Imposible salvo Quizás por
una posibilidad Que de momento Europa
sigue descartando a qué me refiero pues
prestad mucha atención al siguiente mapa
en él podéis ver los resultados de un
estudio de 2011 de la agencia de
información energética de los Estados
Unidos que buscó gran parte de las
reservas de gas de esquisto estimadas en
el mundo
[Música]
además un informe de la propia comisión
europea en 2017 evaluó 49 de las 81
formaciones de escrito estimadas en el
viejo continente según este informe
Europa tendría como mínimo 90 billones
con b de metros cúbicos de gas de
escrito esto para que nos entendamos
sería suficiente como para cubrir casi
dos siglos del actual consumo de Europa
Es evidente que con estos datos es muy
posible que si Europa se pusiera las
pilas las nuevas explotaciones de gas
viables económicamente pudieran cubrir
buena parte de su consumo
es decir que la diferencia entre Estados
Unidos y Europa es básicamente que en la
potencia norteamericana han apostado por
hacer negocio con esta industria pero no
nos desviemos porque pese a todo esta
posibilidad no parece estar en los
planes de Bruselas como veis Estados
Unidos se está convirtiendo en un actor
del primerísimo nivel en el mercado
Internacional del gas un nuevo negocio
que le reportará decenas y decenas de
miles de millones de dólares cada año
ahora bien Europa tiene otro problema no
es el único cliente que compite por este
tipo de gas os habéis preguntado por qué
se ha incrementado de repente tanto el
precio del gas pues atentos
la guerra del gas
la guerra en Ucrania y las sanciones
europeas al gas ruso no Solo han
disparado los precios del gas también
han hecho temblar los propios cimientos
del mercado Y es que veréis los países
como Corea del Sur o Japón que más han
apostado desde hace años por el gas
natural licuado lo hicieron porque hasta
ahora era una fuente de suministro
relativamente estable y poco volátil un
mercado fiable y predecible con pocos
altos en los precios que aseguraba un
suministro seguro y constante sin
embargo todo eso ahora ha saltado por
los aires ya no existe en el momento en
el que preparamos Este vídeo el mercado
del lng es lo más parecido a un bazar
hablamos de un mercado en el que el
mejor postor se lo lleva todo
y dada la escasez que existe podríamos
decir que cada dos por tres vemos
auténticas bofetadas y es que veréis
aunque los contratos de largo plazo se
respetan hay una parte de la demanda que
se cubría con el mercado spot es decir
comprando barco a barco y ahora Este
mercado concreto está totalmente
descontrolado De hecho hay países de
bajos recursos que corren el riesgo de
quedarse sin gas básicamente por no
poder pagarlo los compradores del sur de
Asia de nuevo marginados por los altos
precios del LG al contado por poneros un
ejemplo de lo que esto supone no son
pocos los casos de barcos que ya
cargados de lng y navegando hacia Asia
de repente se dan la vuelta hacia Europa
simple y llanamente porque algún
comprador está ofreciendo pagar más esto
ocurre sobre todo con los cargamentos
que proceden de Estados Unidos y
Australia que se rigen por el conocido
como sistema free on Board en este caso
el intermediario que compra el gas es
propietario de este recurso desde el
preciso momento en el que los barcos se
cargan Así que durante el tiempo que
tardan en llegar a Puerto siguen
negociando en busca de un mejor postor
El caso es que esto ha desatado una
enorme guerra de pujas entre Europa y
Asia lo que por supuesto ha contribuido
a disparar los precios
[Música]
si de media el pasado año 2021 el lng de
Estados Unidos se vendió a entre 4 y 8
dólares por millón de unidades térmicas
británicas ahora el precio de los
futuros se ha disparado hasta los 60
incluso 70 dólares esto supone que en
apenas un año el precio se ha llegado a
multiplicar por 15 y no solo eso en
total el lng exportado Europa Durante
los primeros tres meses del 2022 se pagó
una media de más de 30 dólares es decir
unas siete veces más caros que apenas un
año antes
[Música]
y es que obviamente los países europeos
y especialmente En aquellos donde hay
inviernos más fríos o industria más
intensiva en gas están intentando a toda
Costa y a cualquier precio rellenar sus
reservas para el invierno y eso eso ha
hecho reventar el mercado pero bien
Ahora que ya sabemos el papel que puede
jugar Estados Unidos y también por qué
el precio del gas se ha vuelto loco La
pregunta es para ti realmente piensas
que Estados Unidos puede ser una
alternativa clara al gas ruso los países
europeos resistir el frío invierno y la
escasez de gas hasta que la
infraestructura de lng esté
completamente lista qué más alternativas
existen podéis dejarnos vuestras
respuestas en los comentarios y ahora si
este vídeo te ha resultado interesante
No olvides darle al botón de like y
suscribirte si aún no lo has hecho
muchas gracias por estar ahí un saludo y
hasta la próxima
[Música]